je te le dis c'est un super appartement
waouh janet on se calme tu en as vu
combien est signé le bail sort là tout
ça ira mais les jeannettes à 24 ans elle
vit sa vie elle a un travail elle a un
petit ami un mail à mon nouvel
appartement
je voulais seulement dire bonsoir je
suis votre nouvelle voisine une fille
l'appartement nuit dans un endroit a
sauté du balcon et elle est morte
cet appartement me fait flipper et
jeunes filles comment tu as fait pour
être là avant moi
je te dis qu'il ya un truc bizarre dans
cet appartement parti loin
sa paire vers et de cours qu'est ce
qu'il ya quelqu'un dans la peau je veux
rentrer chez nous
hahaha
un appartement ne tue personne une
personne tuée une personne